so let's jump right into him yeah what
is web assembly so from now on I
probably gonna call it often buzzing
because it's shorter than whatever
assembly but it means the same thing we
will see rosin throughout the whole
workshop so don't get it I hope it don't
get you confused or something the cool
thing is why web assembly also really
took off in the last couple of months or
years is because browser support has to
has increased a lot so you see like
maybe two years ago you would have to
start Chrome with certain flags that web
assembly is actually available to you
but nowadays it's readily available in
all the browsers that you actually want
to use obviously since I 11 is not being
actively developed anymore right I 11
contently about H Safari Firefox Chrome
they all have a good implementation of
web assembly 1.0 we will talk a bit
about that what is what is going to come
in the next couple of months or years so
this is the first web assembly version
so what is vasn't apps actually so so
what do we have to think of when we talk
about web assembly basically it's byte
code for the browser right we can we can
actually send a binary to the browser
and it will run in a VM with near native
performance so whatever we can compile
to that format will be able to run in
the browser right away no need for any
backends no need for any other calls you
get your binary you tell the browser run
that in that web assembly VM and it will
just just work we will see that later on
it's actually a first I think or one of
the first times that all the browser
vendors including Apple were really able
to sit at the table and say this is the
format we all support our no prefixes
there's nothing else in it so they
really all have the same VM well the
same implementation of it that's really
cool in my opinion
but you might ask what languages can
actually be compiled to a samurai can I
use Java can I use go language so I
included a list of or a github
repository where somebody actually
curated or is has a curated list of
languages that are supported currently
so this is basically just a list of
languages that have a compiler that can
compile to the yasm so you see here
there are hatched eggs or hatched
chickens and eggs so the ones with the X
they are not there yet but the ones with
the hatched chickens are very good
supported so you see the C language is
like C and C++ they are very good
supported we have go which is good
supported we have Lua and I think
brainfuck right so if you want to write
brain-fuck go ahead and rust that's
actually what we will be using a bit
throughout this workshop don't worry if
you don't know rust that well you don't
need any in-depth knowledge so we will
have very basic small functions in web
assembly and fool around with them right
so you don't have to know how the memory
management of rust actually works how
all the details of all the types are we
will just have a very basic set so don't
worry about that I hope it will be will
not be overwhelming at all so let's look
at a small compilation example that we
have kind of understand what happens
behind the scenes so this is a little C
code can you all see that is to contrast
okay enough is it good okay so this is a
little C function that does factorial
right you probably all know that if we
make if you have the factorial of 5 you
would multiply 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 which would then be hundred and
20 so a very easy function that is
recursive so we call ourselves with n
minus 1 or yeah n minus 1
so we would first compile that in an
intermediate format so from there it
will be easier to compile it to actual
webassembly
so you still see some of you might be a
bit more familiar with code like that so
you can kinda figure out what that would
do or maybe you can at least kind of
draw some some lines between here and
the C code we saw before right you might
think like okay
I see kind of there is the integer and
we do something with that and in the end
it will look like that so obviously we
are all able to read that right away
right we are programmers so we just see
that like the matrix and we see oh yeah
obviously this is factorial yeah no I
just wanted to to show this is the
actual format that will be sent over the
line
so that you saw it there's also a text
representation of that whole thing so
this is what it looks like when we are
using the IDE later on when we will
program a bit if you click on device and
binary you will see that code actually
this is not what will be sent to the
browser this is just a format for us
that we can actually read at least to a
certain extent right you can kinda see
what's happening so what we actually do
here this is but this is not what we
will send to the browser we will
actually send a binary to the browser
not this string representation this is
just for us so we can see the bit or we
can at least least read it a bit so
let's come to the limitations right so
we have seen we can compile cool so can
we compile anything that's does
everything where to do we have like any
native function you could think about
unfortunately no so let's first talk
about memory memory management is a huge
thing right we probably all struggled
with it once at least what web assembly
has is flat linear memory if if that
doesn't really ring a bell with you this
means pretty much you have one array and
every element of the array is one byte
so if you would have one kilobyte of
memory you will have a array with 1024
elements every element would be
one byte so fairly easy right you can
just navigate on that array if you want
to do some pointer magic you can just
increase and decrease your pointer and
read any byte that you want to have
until you get some out of memory
exception or index out of bounds
exception what it doesn't happen this is
a very important thing this is also why
you saw Java is not quite there yet
it's not a hatched egg it's still kind
of in that breathing state we don't have
garbage collection so this means we we
have a memory array and if you are with
C or C++ you are you're you see right
you free your own memory so that works
but languages that use garbage
collection don't work out of the box so
that's a big thing we will talk about
later but it's working progress I will
come to that point so if you thought
like you can send a binary to the
browser and they can just run as a whole
web application as of now this is not
really the case we don't have access to
all the browser stuff so for example Dom
is missing so if we have our C program
we can't go like document query element
and then we will just get a Dom node
currently this is not supported but this
is one of the bigger issues that is
being discussed and is proposed for one
of the upcoming upcoming versions of
Basel then this is a this is quite a
high limitation if you want to do a lot
of hardcore computing where you want to
have the leverage of the GPU so you can
actually be fast or how fast math
currently there is no cheap you access
and it's not really planned because it's
a very hard discussion there is so much
to discuss about how you actually access
the different graphics cards with all
their different architectures and
different programming languages so this
is something that is being discussed but
it's not like as a big priority
currently so I'm sorry if you want to
have your blockchain minor in the
browser not yeah unfortunately because
CPU mining is not that good right but
also what's maybe a bit of a
better actual use case that we have
heavy machine learning is often done on
the GPU so you can't do that right now
so when we do machine learning stuff we
are limited to CPU CPU calculations then
one of the biggest limitations that we
will stumble across right from the
beginning is there aren't many types in
web assembly that doesn't mean like your
C code can't use all its types right C
can use any type it wants I mean it has
direct memory access it just does what
it wants but the interface between
browsers and web assembly basically has
these four types or these five types we
have integers 32 and 64 bits we have
floats 32 and 64 bits and real functions
but this is pretty much all we have - we
have on earth that we can actually use
for the first couple of exercises we
will basically be sending integers forth
and back so that's kind of a limitation
but this is being worked on - so what we
do when we want to exchange other types
so we are back to pointer arithmetic
right so what we would do is if we take
a rust example we would allocate memory
for a string and rust would write that
string into that memory then take the
pointer the pointer is an integer right
so we send that integer through the
interface get it to JavaScript
JavaScript on its side has access from
the from from above right to the web
assembly memory so what it does is it
takes a pointer goes into that array
reach the string until the first 0
because C strings for example are 0
null-terminated so it reads until it
finds the first 0 thus interpret every
byte as a utf-8 byte and voila we have
our string in JavaScript it's not very
cool but we will do it later on so you
will see how it does so this is what we
kind of have to
now but we will see that later so don't
worry about it too much
but what is coming right we want to know
okay these are the limitations for what
should be coming and one of the first
things is also the first things I
mentioned at the limitations actually
since garbage collection is not
supported right now all the languages
that use a garbage collector can I have
to do their own garbage collector then
compile it down to Assam and then send
it with your actual binary to the
browser so the browser instantiates your
Watson code plus that sent garbage
collector that will then work in web
assembly so Russ does it that way for
example obviously not very good for
binary size and and the whole efficiency
so what they are working on now is that
you have some basic garbage collection
in web assembly right away so you don't
have to send your own garbage collector
we don't want to be writing our own
garbage collectors right then another
big thing is host bindings this is
actually cool so this would mean we can
actually take Tom notes sent them to web
assembly or even create the web assembly
the Dom nodes in webassembly sent them
forth and back transform them update and
delete them so the host bindings
proposal is very cool and would actually
allow us to do a lot of things then what
I didn't mention with the limitations
multi-threading so threats should be
coming soon what they were thinking is
that you can have an abstraction over
threats so not every browser has to deal
with every or your web assembly code
doesn't have to deal with on which
operating system it runs right and which
way it does create a threat so what they
were thinking is you already have
threats in the web with web workers
right so you can already kind of have
threats so they would leverage what is
existing and would take that to web
assembly so you could actually have
threats in the form or in the same way
that web workers will work or kind
same way.not not exactly the same way
then one of the biggest problems I think
everybody everyone in here has struggled
with that right exception having every
language has its own concept we have a
lot of various exception handling
mechanisms and we will see that later on
webassembly doesn't have one yet so if
you see code fails this can be very hard
to debug and kind of find out what
actually happened
because the exception is not like going
up to JavaScript then we can just have a
try-catch around it this is not working
currently but it should be in probably
more of the far future I would say
because if you go to the github
repository or web assembly and follow
that issue you will see there's a lot of
discussions and this goes way beyond
what I understand so I don't even try to
explain that to you here reference types
is very closely coupled to the host
bindings approach so this would mean
that we actually leverage that interface
to have that any ref type so we can pass
in various kind of types and references
this would be closely coupled to the
host binding so both of them would kind
of be have to be solved for it to work
properly and to a cool extent and
there's a lot more so there's a cool
list of that I think where is it oh yeah
the guy Colin Everhart he has a very
goodness about that if you're gonna have
a look at that he has really every
proposal there is in which phase it is
what he thinks about it what he thinks
is the actual hard part about it so if
you want to read more about that and you
want to really go into all the details
all the nitty gritty details check that
out really cool blog post in my opinion
you will have access to my presentation
later on so you will have all these
links cool
so that's it very short a brief
introduction to webassembly
the theory before we go into our first
exercises so do you have any questions
at that moment still feeling okay ish
retired from lunch probably right cool
so let's move on let's go let's go to
the actual exercises the fun stuff right
cool where are we here we are so let's
try out the basic suburb assembly what I
just kind of talked about we want to
build and run some code that's what we
are here for at least I hope that's what
you are here for right so we're going to
take ruffs for a for a minute so I will
do probably the shortest rusty
introduction you will ever get and it
will not be in any way even closely to
be complete so we'll just look at a very
very easy function declaration this one
fairly easy function I think what it
does everybody of you see what it does
it adds one to a given integer so this
is hardcore math right we will be so
fast if that and JavaScript would be so
slow with that no obviously not
but let's look at the Ross function so
what is it so the first thing we notice
is that little flag up at the top of our
function
it says no mangle I hope you can all
read that from the contrast what it does
is basically just tell the compiler hey
please don't change the name of that
function and don't remove it because you
see that nobody actually calls it right
if you would use the rest compiler
without that he would just remove the
function and the binary would get his
zero bytes because he says yeah you
don't call that function so I'm gonna
optimize it away
good job so with no mango we can
actually tell the compiler please don't
do that we need to be able to call that
function by name so changed in a please
don't change the name and please don't
remove it because yeah
so with public excellency we say rust
that this function will be called from
externally and it will be called by AC
like language so what Russ does is make
sure that a see compiled language can
actually call that external function and
this is what we will have when we call
it over the web assembly interface you
would actually not have to write that C
that's kind of the default of rust but I
did include it here so you have the
whole example so you see what's actually
going on so this is the function
declaration I think that's actually
pretty similar to what you would see
with typescript or maybe you are used to
CoffeeScript or something the only thing
that you see here is the 32-bit integer
so we get one parameter in called X and
we will return one 32-bit integer I
think simple right and this is the
actual block the actual function so what
do you notice here there is no return
statement if you want to you can always
add a return but rust doesn't need you
to rust will just return the last
expression you have in your block so if
you're feeling lazy today yesterday
you don't need semicolons you don't need
return statements with rust if you want
to do them either way they will not hurt
you so whatever you like cool but since
I don't want you to have to install the
rust compiler right
we have Linux Mac OS Windows certainly
would would work on some of the machines
and on the Sun we would just have some
weird issues I'm gonna use the web
assembly studio an awesome project by
the Mozilla group or a Mozilla company
it is an online --day ide that allows us
to actually write rust or C or I think
there is where were some assembly script
but we're gonna reuse rust today so we
can write our code in there and directly
compile and run it from there
which is amazing in my opinion so if I
can ask you all to try to go
- dad URL when I tried it last time
somebody was trying it with H and it
wasn't working with H I should work with
Firefox Safari and Chrome so I hope
there's nobody like wanting to hard card
use H so you can try it
yeah is everybody in the Wi-Fi the Wi-Fi
password would be over there otherwise
Sol la Sol chairs comes with the Wi-Fi
and chose confession would be the
password
when you go in there you will get that
little assistant over here please select
the simple roast project the empty rust
project we will go step by step until we
kind of reached at lower hello world
Ross project please don't open that yet
because it will have pretty much
everything in there but we will kind of
try to go step by step until we kind of
until we finally understand what the
hello world project actually does so
please go into the empty Ross project
and let's see what we have there since I
want to try to code a bit too here I
have to do it like that okay so if you
open the empty Russ project you will see
that source folder over here here are
the three files that we are actually
interested in the HTML Javascript and
the rust so first of all if you go to
the rust file you will see that this is
absolutely one-to-one the function that
we just looked at right so nothing too
fancy here you have just heard about
that function cool
if you click build up here like there is
a build command if you hit that you will
see there is a output on the bottom task
field is running and then build complete
what you will notice is now you have an
out folder and there's the myosin file
so this is our binary as mentioned
before if you click on that you will
actually see these s expressions that we
were talking about earlier if you really
want to watch or I want to take a look
at the binary you can right click on
that file name and somewhere down here
you would have view as binary and this
helps us a lot right
cool but if you want to look at it this
is what actually will be sent to the
browser just so you know this is not the
real format
nice but we see here we have a function
that is exported called add one and
there's some inter 232 param and the
results that is integer 32 so what we
would expect right nothing too fancy
around here so let's look at the Java
Script what do we need to actually get
that running and I will be reformatting
that quickly a little bit so it's easier
to read for us or at least I hope it is
easier to read for us so let's have a
look at that yeah it's it big enough do
you can you read it otherwise just
scream and say cool I hope everybody in
here knows fetch right so we just fetch
a file out main Razzles so this is it
right we know that file then what we do
is we create an array buffer out of it
and that will be handed directly to web
assembly so if you go to your browser
console nowadays you will see you have
that webassembly object right on your
window object so every browser nowadays
hasa
you can't just use it like that what we
can do is we take this array of bytes
and instantiate the web assembly
instance out of it cool a promise and it
will return us this result on that
results we have the instance and this is
finally finally our wasm interface right
so here we are you see over here there's
an expert's on that object so this is
where all the exporter functions of our
bottom of our running lesson will be
located at and as you probably guessed
right we are going to call that one
function yay what we're gonna do is we
expect there to be a return value and we
will add that to that element called I
with the ID container if you look at the
HTML
I think couldn't be much more easy than
that right so you have a span that is
called
Taney was a surprise and the script that
we fetch right main touch is the one we
see over here nothing too fancy going on
so the HTML will take the JavaScript
JavaScript will fetch the yasm file will
instantiate it call that one function on
it and we'll show this to the browser
so let's he'll hit build again and
there's one important thing that you
have to know if you don't save it you
see it here I have that I have that
circle if you don't save it and you
click build it will not take in your
changes your changes are only in the
compile step if you save it so don't
forget just press ctrl or command S
whatever operating system you are on and
this circle up here will disappear now
when you hit build and run voila
disappear I hope you all see that can
you try that out if you have build and
run we will sent a dress code I think
it's done on the server we'll compile it
make that ransom file load it into the
browser give it 41 the rust will
actually add that plus one and then we
will output it to our browser again does
this not work for anybody or is
everybody happy everybody sees 42 the
answer to all of our questions perfect
nice to see so this is easy right
so let's go in to be this a bit more so
that was maybe too easy so yeah okay
let's have a quick look at the
instantiation I already explained that
we have to do an array buffer and
webassembly doesn't Stan she eight
expects us to have array buffer because
it is a binary file right we can't
really do anything else with it we can't
kind of make a chase on out of it or
something so an array buffer is properly
probably the appropriate format of that
hole
there is a new method instantiate
streaming it's called so we don't have
to deal with the array buffer this is
all done internally so here we can just
add the fetch out of the fetch promise
that we get back into that instantiate
streaming it will be handled by web
sembly or the web assembly api and we
don't have to care about your a buffer
anymore this is cool and a little bit
more performant when you have very big
binaries that can make a difference but
unfortunately we have a new IE here so
Safari is not yet on that but I should
have it hopefully soon as of yesterday I
think it wasn't in there but I hope it
will be will be soon oh that's the wrong
around but now let's talk about I mean
it's all fun right we we call the
function we get an integer back not very
interesting we want to kind of have this
ability to have a callback right tell
rust as soon as you're done call us back
because we are JavaScript developers
there's only one way to pass values and
it's callbacks cool there is the import
object you see on both of these methods
the instantiate and instantiate
streaming there would be a second
parameter that I didn't tell you about
earlier so next to our array byte array
of bytes we could also input a import
object let's have a look at how that
will look like that import object can
have functions on it and we can actually
pass that into rust at that point and
rust will see these functions and will
actually be able to call them so this is
this is getting cooler right so we get
some functionality done on here so how
is that actually done let's look at the
JavaScript for data first you notice I'm
just I named it import object a very
simple JavaScript object then there is
one property that we have to set its and
this is just expected so all the import
functions interests should be on that
end proper
otherwise I think during the build step
the IDE will complain and say hey your
import object doesn't have an end
property so please add that otherwise
you won't be able to actually call your
functions so and if it's just another
object then in here finally our
functions are situated so cool things
and as we know I want a debug right so I
need console log so what I do is I call
it log results as one parameter and I
will just call console log in it so the
cool thing is here right I'm back other
JavaScript functions so my scope is
actually what you would expect if that
JavaScript function so we are not in
some fancy pantsy scoping or something
when ruff calls us we are exactly at
that scope you would expect so this is
cool
we can use all these window methods we
could use other variables and functions
that will be in our scope like you would
expect it to work
this is fairly cool and in the end you
see webassembly instantiate we have to
ask that import object in there and
we're done on the rough side so the
compiler will obviously complain and say
no no no you call a function that isn't
existing at compile time so we have to
tell the rust compiler please trust us
we will have that function at runtime
you don't see it anchored at compile
time but that doesn't mean it won't work
we will promise you we will add that
function at one time so this is the
external block with rust we can say that
and say there's a function it will be
called log result and since we can't
pass strings yet we will just pass an
integer so we will say you can put in
one integer and it's a 32-bit integer we
will obviously look in this a bit more
afterwards so that we can have our
proper hello world project but now
whether for now we have to stick to
integers
what will it look like then in rust so
if you take the same function as before
you see there is no return type anymore
obviously we call a function right we
don't return an integer anymore
and we have that unsafe block before we
call the function why do we need that
unsafe block Russ tries to be safe like
he tries to or he the compiler tries to
make as many assertions as possible and
tries to help you as much as possible so
you won't screw it up right you won't
shoot yourself in the foot so what it
does it will tell you well this is an
external block I can't help you on that
so you have to wrap your call in an
unsafe block so I actually know this is
expected to be unsafe I can't have all
my assertions on there so as soon as we
have that unsafe block we we won't get
any upsetting messages from our Russ
compiler anymore
he will just wave it through and say ok
you seem to know what you do I hope you
do let's just go ahead and compile that
cool so I have to quickly check
something there should be a QR code
somewhere around here I think I skipped
it and I'm very sorry that was around
here yes I'm sorry so this presentation
is actually on the web so all the
exercises have these code snippets in
there so please follow my presentation
if you open either bits of Lee's large
web assembly - workshop or scan the QR
code you will get to my index page this
is the page that you saw before from
there you can open these various
presentations so every chapter every
chapter is an own presentation so keep
that index open so we'll always have the
possibility to jump into any chapter you
want to did everybody get the link
everybody on the page perfect so now we
are at three chapter three so if you
open that you will get to this slide
over here so please take a look at these
arrows so usually what I do is I have
these kind of topics and we have an
exercise we will go down vertically so
you can navigate with your arrows or you
can click on these arrows so whenever we
are in an exercise you have to navigate
vertically to find the code examples
that you will be using for that current
exercise so now we are at
here cultures functions from rust if you
hit escape you will get into this
overview so this is actually the last
exercise for that chapter can go into
here and then you see all these code
blocks and in the end you have the link
again for web assembly studio so let's
try to do that let's try to call a
JavaScript function from rust so you
have all the code examples that you use
to create this exercise go to web
assembly studio try to recreate that and
if you have any questions I'll be around
just come and ask me or I will come to
you let's take like 10 15 minutes let's
see how long you need for that and then
discuss the exercise just got a very
good question so how do you see the
console of that your actual browser
console is the console for that either
IDE so if you open up your console you
will see whatever you do with console
log and stuff like that so you should
see it in here
cool did it work for everyone anyone
having problems with it we can otherwise
look at it in the break if you want to
because we are already almost there but
let's quickly go through this oh so I've
been higher it slowly so that's quickly
go to their web assembly project and
just do what we said so I think a lot of
you noticed you can actually just copy
paste the code from here it will work or
it should work that's so what we need
I'm sorry this is a bit can never can
anybody can everybody read that right
cool so we have the import object over
here just add it like that there is no
return value in the end for this so a
lot of people noticed it themselves you
can remove that here don't have to but
in the end we want to call log result
right we don't have to return anything
anymore from the add one function yeah
so let's take the rust external block
over here yes
make sure that this no mangle is
directly above your function if you take
this away and like move it up to here
the compiler will not care about it
anymore because it's only meant to be on
top of a function so the compiler
actually knows this function will be
staying in there forever
okay so now we only have to call this
log result with X plus let's multiply up
for once and this is important here when
I don't return anything anymore I need
to remove that type right if I leave
that then the compiler will tell me no
no no so I figure look at that you see
now rust is always returning the last
expression so what he says is I expect
it to return an integer 32-bit but what
you did is you returned a function call
since log result is a function call so
these messages down here I think the
rest compiler is actually quite a nice
compiler it helps you with rather nice
messages so always take a look at the
output down here usually it helps so
let's remove that and the last thing we
have to do ask that unsafe block so this
is all let's quickly try it out if it
really works what build and run so yeah
I think a lot of you already struggled
with that command s all the time I'm
sorry we are not used to that anymore
right that we have to save manually
okay you see 82 and also what I said
before actually in your browser console
you see this is no trick we really put
in the console log function that we
think we put in cool so that's it for
the first part that was easy right oh
yeah you can't see the quiz already
okay if you want to go check that out
web assembly on MDM I mean as always
Mozilla developer Network documentation
just fantastic and webassembly studio is
actually an open source project you can
go i mean maybe you've seen that there's
a github issues but when you write you
can go there you can check it out you
can build it on your own machine and run
it locally very cool
so you don't need internet for it to
work I think to learn and teach like
this actually a very cool project so
this will already be our first short
break so you can kind of maybe go pee
and drink something and we will see you
again in 15 minutes so for 10 minutes
after 2:00 so that I'm clear
mr. reporting yeah
the school is getting combined exactly
yeah
what exactly is through this oh okay
something now I think I brushed over at
a bit this is the actual rust compiler
so what the web assembly
what the studio down here does I will
explain that after a short break
there is a built there's a built type
script file I should have explained that
I will do that after the break
yes can we directly open the browser
also because like we have some HTML
content over there is it possible this
window HTML file I downloaded from there
so if I download this all this file
comes GSRs and main door HTML so okay if
everyone still here doesn't work that
way
well that's ok they will get back soon I
see people coming cool are there any
unanswered questions right now there's
something I didn't really explain all
that well so I will try to explain that
now some people asked me how does this
actually gets compiled right I didn't
really tell you that so over there and
there's ability as that ominous file and
this is how this is actually being built
and let's quickly look into it so we use
code still people using gulp today
Oh a few few that's cool
I haven't used count for a while so this
was a kind of a reminder for me that I
don't know it anymore so we have one
task here built and you see there is
this service if you go look at web
assembly studio github repository you
will find they have a little service
here which will make a call to their
back-end so what's happening here is we
get to file main rust and we send it to
the backend to be compiled we say look
this is a rust file and we want you to
build it for web assembly what we will
get back is that object called data we
will see it later on and then we will
create
here project a new file out main rather
this one and we'll set they turn to what
we go back from the background so the
JavaScript the JavaScript code doesn't
have to compile now right
but the rust code has to compile and we
can't really compile rust in the browser
probably it would be possible somehow
right but it's easier now so what they
do is send it to the backend
let it be compiled on the backend and
get the binary back and I create a file
with it so we have to fire an action
binary file we will look into that a
little bit later I was always also
getting the question like rust is
another webassembly only language rust
wasn't invented with kind of web
assembly in mind I think it's more of a
coincidence that when they actually came
out with rust that web assembly was
right there so they said let's make web
assembly one of the default or one of
the easy to access compilation targets
so this is basically everything
it is rust you could also obviously
compile rust just to an executable and
then run it on any machine you want that
they support this is just cool and it
was very easy for me to make these
teaching cases here right so that's why
I was using rust so we don't compile
rust to see or any say anything here we
come
pile rust to webassembly binary just a
little clarification about that
okay so let's go to our in-depth
exercises that webassembly
in depth so I mean it's all fun right we
passed some integers but that's not
really mind-blowing like why would we
pass integers in these functions it
doesn't really help us a lot and the use
cases well maybe we have that extremely
hard to calculate math function okay
maybe that could be something that is
cool but let's be honest what we want to
do is we want to pass arbitrary data
right we want to we want to be able to
really have an API where we can pass
what every every we want so how do we
handle these kind of complex types let's
start with not the most complex type
right string currently some of you might
have tried that if you want to pass a
string it will fail miserably you will
get fancy exception messages that this
is not working so Watson currently only
knows these integers and floats types as
I mentioned before integer 32 and 64-bit
and float 32 64 bits so what we have to
do to actually be able to pass strings
is in rust we will allocate memory on
our linear memory array right the string
into there take the pointer return it
because the pointer is an integer is
32-bit right so we can take that point
to return it from our function to
JavaScript so javascript now has an
index right it's like 1347 or something
whatever that just points to an element
in the memory array so we go to the web
assembly part in JavaScript take the
memory out of there well the memory
array and say I want to read the byte at
that position and then I'm going to
increase and read every byte until I
find a byte that is 0 because we are
gonna deal with the C
string implementation that means we have
utf-8 strings every byte is the utf-8
byte and it will be finished by a zero
as soon as we read a zero we know we're
done if we read over it you will get
that classical in exile offense
exception and stuff like that so let's
not do that
yeah so how does that look so now we get
into rust a little bit more bear with me
here for a quick while it's not that
complicated so you see we have some
imports we have another return type and
we do some fancy stuff here with C
strings so let's break it down part by
part so in rust usually stuff is
immutable so when we have mutable things
we will prepend and beauty for mutable
for all of you that now C or C++ that
asterisk means we have a pointer we will
not return the string we will return the
pointer to the memory location where
that string is in and the C char is kind
of an alias bye-bye rust that is the C
type so since C types are native they
were I a bit from architecture to
architecture so rust made like one
heylia's for that char character type
and c that is called c underscore char
so this means nothing else that we are
handling a c type in here so in the
memory there will be that character type
of c then we have this a higher-level
construct of rust the C string object so
this is for us that has a lot of these
helpers on it so we can actually
instantiate it do things with it like
you know it from from other high level
languages right we have just this string
helpers so what we can do we take that
in here make new so we have that C
string object now this means the base is
down below is what I just mentioned
before we have
the string that is now null-terminated
so there will be a zero in the end when
we write that to the memory there will
be a zero at the end this is important
for us because otherwise we would
probably fail then as soon as we have
that C string object we have to make
sure that we get to that point in turn
so the first thing is we do the first
thing we do is unwrap it what that means
is it will take like an unboxing it will
take away that C string stuff and we
will be left with that C character type
this is what we want then with in tirol
we will convert it to a pointer instead
of the actual type we will have a
pointer in our hand this is what we want
also a very relevant side effect of that
rust will not garbage-collected right we
have to care about that if we don't use
that variable rust will eventually go
ahead and say oh I don't need that
string anymore and kill it and if we are
in Chaves europe trying to read that yet
this this will not work right this will
throw an exception obviously so interro
will do that for us we will have a
pointer and rust will not
garbage-collected anymore but memory
leaks I hear you say so now rust is not
garbage collecting it anymore
it is not on the channel skipped not on
the Chava script heap so that means
JavaScript is not garbage collecting it
either so what happens is it will stay
in that memory and not good
not good but obviously we can fix that
and please bear with me here this is a
hack I know that but it will do what we
want so we can have another function
that is called deallocate string it will
take exactly that pointer that we just
returned right appointed to a seed
character and what it will do is it will
instantiate a variable from that string
and not use that variable anymore so
rust will garbage collector your engine
it eventually it's not life you know so
we're just creating a stupid very
everyone is good for nothing but with
that kind of hack we give the garbage
collection back to rust we say hey here
take that string and when you don't use
it anymore free the memory that's what
we do here this is just a helper
function this is not what we want to
look into it most but this this will
help us not make memory leaks so you
will never have to care about weird
memory issues yeah you saw up here
there's again our lovely little unsafe
block this one here right we need that
because we are reading an arbitrary
pointer you could pass in any
interpreter rust can't validate that so
it doesn't know is that an actual
pointer to our memory or will it
overflow the memory is it type safe you
say this is a C character right but you
just give me a pointer it could be
anything so everybody who had to work
with C++ at some point it probably knows
the issues around dangling pointers and
stuff like that so we have to tell rust
please just trust us we are engineers we
know what we are doing probably
so we have the rest part we make a
string we return it as a pointer and we
have an infection that we can call to
deallocate that string again
so the rough side it's already but the
Chava script side is not yet there so
you see there's a little function here
it looks very nice and fluffy at all
that's copy C string function I mean how
hard can it be to read from memory right
oh yeah that's it so I don't expect you
to fully understand that if you want to
go ahead take a look at it what it
basically does is we have a generator
function up here and this is looping
over the memory with that wire and you
see it will stop when it hits a zero
what I said before right we start as a
certain pointer we loop over each byte
in the array and we will when we will
hit the zero we say get we're done we
have the whole string if there is no
zero with a loop and loop and loop and
loop and we will eventually crash so
let's hope that doesn't happen so what
we do here you into eight array so
unsigned integer array then we have to
decode it right so now we have an array
of bytes so we basically have a copy of
that memory snippet where the string is
and this is this is relevant to get we
now have a copy so JavaScript has that
string in its own heap now as I copy
it's still in the web assembly part
that's why we have to free the memory
but JavaScript copied the string now
what we need to do is the text decoder
utf-8 we know each of these bytes is a
utf-8 character so we have to tell
JavaScript hey redefined as utf-8
characters and voila we should get a
string in the end hopefully and what you
see down here this is where we call it
so we take that original pointer you see
that up here
safe this point to that we get in we
save it initially and then in the end as
soon as we have copied that string we
call that funny little D allocation
method here so rust will garbage collect
a string that is not the Bassam memory
so we don't have to care about that
anymore and in the end we return that
string so this is now a utf-8 decoded
string cool and this is what we will do
now yeah so yeah we are in chapter 4
handling complex types you can go down
here all the code you need is basically
in here go ahead try it out and in the
end if everything works we are very
close to having a proper hello world
function yeah I think we we take 15
minutes for that I would say because
this is a little bit harder
okay I hope that most of you have gotten
this to work this is kind of a cool
little thing when you realize okay now I
read something from memory in JavaScript
I've never done that before like this is
let's say the most low-level thing I've
done in JavaScript so let's try it out
so I'm gonna try that quickly too let's
remove what I have here I just add that
in write the second function in we saw
here the ad deallocation this one so
some of the people in here asked me you
need that no mangle in front of every
function otherwise the compiler removes
your function so if you forget one of
these no manuals that's when you
probably get some issues like this is
another function and stuff like that so
you need it in front of every function
so this is all the roughs code we have
right we have two methods welcome
message and the allocate string and I
will remove that import object for now
so it's a bit easier overview for you
guys and then paste that in so make sure
that this JavaScript star is in the them
in here right you need access to that
instance that you just created since
this is asynchronous we can't paste that
code up here right because results is
not accessible from up here because this
will be only available after we loaded
everything so we have to have that code
in here let's remove these two lines oh
cool
this so we instantiate we get the module
results instance experts and then we
call get welcome message then we copy
that see string oh the C string function
so let's copy that as a whole so we
don't have to worry about that
what and when we build and run this it
should say hello from rust oh oh hello
from rust cool so what we did is we
passed for interest yeah point alertness
arithmetic we read from that memory so
you might have seen this year we just
access module dot memory web assembly is
actually exporting this memory object
for us so this is how we can access that
buffer so the actual array where we can
work on right we need that so this is
the memory from rust in web assembly
that we access here right away and yeah
as soon as you see hello from Russell's
down here you have actually saved AC
string into a memory and read it from
JavaScript and passed it as utf-8 but
this is a bit hard right I mean we don't
have with the string it's easy
well easy we can't just read until
zeroes but try to pass now arbitrary
objects with arrays in it that's where
it's gonna get really heavy so we don't
want to do that and we don't need to do
that so there's a good tuning for us I
only wanted to show you this so you
would actually know what happens
underneath it that you understand this
has to be done because we only can pass
integers and floats but we're not gonna
do that anymore now now we're gonna have
one abstraction between us and web
assembly so it's gonna be easier for us
to stay sane in our head so every
every current language that we can
compile to webassembly has its own kind
of helping tool for that in rust is
called rosin banchon for c and c++ you
might have heard of that
it's called em scripting people that
know as in chess know and scripting is
around for quite some time now but yeah
it allows us to have high-level
interaction so various types and it does
all this post bindings kind of for us so
we can now pass in and out of of
webassembly whatever we feel like and we
will see that this can really be alone
what's also cool is imagine banchon can
actually generate Taipings for you for
typescript so that's in my opinion a
huge boss here that the bat tool does
very well we will not look into that
because of time constraints we won't
have time to explore all the options but
you could theoretically generate
typing's from your rust code so in
typescript you would actually know what
this function is returning and what it
can pass into it at any time which would
be nice the downside of this now we have
a wrapper between web assembly and rust
or the web assembly interface and rust
and JavaScript and the web assembly
interface because when we send some
arbitrary object on the JavaScript side
we kind of have to transform that and
save it into an array and from the rough
side the same right we have to know how
is this kind of stored but we don't want
to see it so we generate code now on the
Chava script side and on the on the
Watson side
rust side and we will only interact with
razzle now through that resin binder
Chan how that looks we will see it right
away so what now happens is when we
compile a resin file it will actually
compile into a JavaScript file and a
file on the JavaScript side we have the
bindings so that we actually know how we
read these arbitrary types and on the
west side we have the compiled dress
code plus also these bindings so
JavaScript and rest know what the other
part is gonna save into memory and read
from memory so we have to kind of
abstract that for us so we have
basically we have three steps to do we
have to make sure that the bust is
compiled with rasma banchon so this is
actually a compiler extension in that
sort then we we need to make sure that
the compiler knows as I mentioned it
will compile it with wise invention and
we will may need to make sure that these
Chinese bindings that I talked about are
loaded into the browser before we access
web assembly because they have to be
there to have to provide us all these
wrappers to to send all these arbitrary
types in and receive them out of we're
assembling how does that look like on
the outside it's it's kind of easy there
is this line up here that helps us with
that oh I'm sorry
this one I will not go into that too
much this is Russ and we save us that we
need some macros to be executed for that
I think that's a detail we just omit for
that workshop so we don't have to go
into rust macros and all that stuff
we're just going to leave that out for a
moment this will activate Wes invention
for the compiler so we can actually use
all of it then we say there's an
external crate the crate is like an NPM
package for rust so there's a massive
engine crate this will actually loads
the library that we will then be using
and here we say that we need this
preload that will help us with all the
helper functions that we will be using
now the actual rust code doesn't look
all that's different you see up here
this is
different instead of no manual vas
invention introduced a new introduces a
new flag
it's called Bassam binds Chen this tells
the compiler for one no mango please
don't remove it but on the other hand it
will also make sure that all these types
are working correctly then you see we
can just return a regular Roth string as
you would expect it that's cool so this
is what we do here but what we get in is
a string reference I will get into why
this is the case this is a little macro
from Russ that is just helping us we can
have these races here and all the
parameters you will add afterwards will
be replaced into these BOTS with the
braces so this is just a fancy print
line right nothing else this will return
a string that is hello comma and then
whatever you pass into it as a name so
the rest function isn't that all that
complicated this is all that we have to
do on the rough side so far so cool yeah
these macros by the way you always see
them because of the exclamation mark
rust has this best yeah rust does this
that every mark row has to have this
exclamation mark in its name but I said
we're not going to look into more of
these markers we just use it for
creating that string that's all it has
to do
so this is the case here that's relevant
javascript strings are utf-16 and they
have some limitations to that so how
pairs are matched up I am way too stupid
to explain this so rust the rust guys
they have done a cool documentation why
it's hard to go from this utf-16 to that
utf-8 of rust without getting these nice
little black boxes with question marks
in it so this is why they give you that
reference they have to do some stuff
that it is guaranteed that that string
will never have unrecognizable
characters in it so this is why you get
a string a reference of a string in the
end there's a base type behind that it's
called a string that's what they use to
actually convert all that stuff if you
want to read up on that these are good
good starting points but this would kind
of be too much for that workshop now so
we're just gonna accept the fact that
when we have something in JavaScript
that we have to when we get a string or
give it back
we'll have this reference reference type
here
so there's one last thing if you recall
the diagram from up above this one when
I showed you that built of TS file
you saw that the Rossum file is only
compiled the rust file is only compelled
into 1000 file and we have to change
that now right because we have these
JavaScript bindings so what webassembly
studio is providing us this is what it
is now right service dot compiled file
but whether service studio actually has
compiled a file with bindings very cool
so what that does is back here we have
the same call we say we enter main rust
it is rust code you have to generate
Watson code and the same options but the
return type is slightly different
because if you look at it before we have
this data object and we would just say a
vassal sets the other but what we do now
is that data object has actually two
properties on it now one is razzin this
is the binary and one is Masum bindings
jeaious binds chain sorry so we create
two files here so this is the basic
difference we have one out main dot
vassal file and we have one main
underscore binding stuff jeaious so now
we created both so we compiled a trust
into javascript and interest Basile
sorry
the only thing that we need to make sure
now is that is actually loaded into HTML
before or other script is actually
so this is I mean it's kind of trivial
right so we just load that main buy
annexed areas that we just created in
the build step and that's all we need to
do so how does the JavaScript side look
like so this is different now you
remember that before we have to call
fetch and array buffer and then whoever
Sam did not instantiate with that buffer
all of this is now done by Wesen binds
chain as I had told you we do not
interact any more directly with Reb
assembly we will interact only through
Masum binds chain this is our
interaction point now to actually get
this code running so the string is the
same right we just say hey take that
file and instantiate and what we get
when that promise returns the instance
is ready web assembly started up and we
can just call it you see that this
function is then calling that treatment
and this is the second thing that is new
up here except instead of having to go
through instance of experts and then
calling doc greet on it
Bassem binds chain is providing us the
experts as these these properties on
that global object so vasin binds chain
is on our window object this is a global
object that we now have and we can get
all the exports from there so if you
want to make it easier and not have
these d structuring things you could
also go ahead and just say vasin on this
carbines chain
dr. greet right this is the same so here
we just have that fancy D structuring so
we take agreed
out of it as a standalone function but
you could also oh well not like this but
like this you could just call it like
that this is just as every window object
properly as you know you have access to
it its global you can't just go ahead
grab whatever you want to and execute it
yeah so maybe if you go to the exercise
delete your existing JavaScript and rust
code and take the ones from these
examples so you don't have any clashes
with names or something so you don't end
up trying to track down some naming
issue or anything so this is all the
code you need for that yeah exactly
that's what I already said that that
main bindings is this is actually the
code
there's the script that does at this
vasin binds chain property to the window
object and we will have access to that
now yeah so there's three things we have
to do we try to pass these strings now
without having to read on the memory
which would be cool right
so make sure that it's compares with
present Bancha and import these bindings
and then you should be all set for that
so let's try that out I would say we
take another 10 to 15 minutes depending
on how many questions there are
nice
but so in a 7 pin package crate is just
extends package the shelf a bus to that
note
they've been may even dependency doesn't
every Ruthie
ok
rust I am NOT a heavy user of Wrath no
but I think we have rust developers but
nah I wouldn't know of any production
project we have a rest I think there are
smaller services when each company has a
kind of thing which is that I use so I
think we have customers that have small
services rather than the rest and go
over a go.you yeah rust is very easy to
teach the basics PO there will be one
more exercise and that will be done with
the basics that we get on to the fun
stuff so let's let's discuss that
okay
so let's discuss this exercise quickly
this will be the second-to-last basic
exercise so bear with me for one more
and then we'll have the fun exercise
where we will actually do a more real
world real world example right because
this helps us understand it but it
doesn't really reflect what we will use
it for afterwards so let's quickly go
through it we import the crates that we
need we ask that one function here to
actually get that hello world message
yeah
then we extend our build step like this
so this isn't that built yes that I
mentioned before right so we take this
one out and X oops
like this replace it with the new one so
in here now you see that we do the main
wasm and that main bindings chairs cool
so we got to rust all set up we get the
build step to do what we want so we need
to import the script in our main HTML
that's around here this one
cool and then there is just the
JavaScript left so let's take that in as
well
nice so if we build and run that now we
should see hello JS conversion
perfect that's what we wanted to see
nice okay so you see now here we have
the main mass of the binary and stock
bindings if you take a look at that
bindings fine so this is all generated
so it's a bit ugly code but if you check
what they do you see that they also use
the text encoder that we used before
they go to the memory buffer as we did
before they do this unsigned integer
array and decode stuff and then you see
the function pass string to Azzam which
allocates memory on the rough side and
then writes the string in the buffer and
everything like that so they pretty much
do what we did before so that's what
wasum invention is now providing us
right so we don't have to care about
that anymore it's not nice couch since
it's generated but now we don't have to
care for ourselves anymore right we
don't have to maintain that memory stuff
and read everything out of there wasn't
binds Chen will take care of this so
that's actually what we wanted very cool
so there's just one thing left and then
we have all the basics covered or yeah
all all major basics covered before we
were able to call JavaScript functions
out of rust can we also pass strings
back to JavaScript right we didn't or
not pass strings back but call a
javascript native function with a string
you haven't proven that yet so this is a
very small exercise
uses bathroom banchon again so you know
that little excerpt blog that we used
earlier for our log results function we
can leverage that a bit and add that was
invention up there what that will do is
wasn't banchon on the JavaScript side
will search for the function and try to
inject that on the instantiation phase
of your web assembly so when we don't
say anything
Masen banshan will go to the global
scope window and will search that
function so this will inject window dot
alert so now we have the window alert
function passed into it we don't need to
do anything on the JavaScript side since
this will all be done in our binding
Australia's that will be generated by
our compile step so the JavaScript it's
not not different this is a thing that
we only have to do on the rough side and
the bass invention will inject the
correct functions now you think like you
have what if I want to have some
specific functions so they have it
covered
if you say nothing there's no flag it
will search for window dot alert if you
say hey hey hey the chance namespace is
console grass invention will go for
window that's console dot log so this is
how we would inject comes along and if
we want to have it twice you know the
console log statement of JavaScript
obviously takes in our arbitrary types
rusts doesn't really know that right
Russ doesn't know that pass me anything
log statement pass me an array or an
object log statement so if you want to
have a second console log injected with
just another typing you see here we say
unsigned
in 32-bit and here we say string
reference you can even go further and
say okay the Chinese namespace is
console and the function name is log but
in Rus that function name will be
console underscore log underscore in you
32 so vas invention will not look at
your function name anymore
it will only check these two variables
if you set them and just from there
we'll search the correct function to
pass into our web assembly code so
lesson banchon we'll set up that import
object it will add the correct functions
into that import object and we'll pass
them in so we don't have to care on the
JavaScript side anymore because that
JavaScript bindings file will do it all
for us start start kinda clear yeah
okay so the question was if you want to
come to look math but look you mean the
JavaScript math that look so what you
would do is another line here and you
would say the JavaScript namespace is
math right so let's just write it if it
would go like that oh this is written
like this so this one now vasin banchon
would now go to window
don't math log so that will now be the
logarithmic function right master
logarithm so now I could go ahead and
say console log underscore you 32 and
call this log function well this is a
bit the naming is not very nice right
because it looks like it's a log
statement but this is math dot love
everything so we would probably go ahead
and say okay that jeaious underscore let
me quickly get that into you so I can
actually write that check his name is
log Matlock and here we would probably
say like math underscore mark and
integer would be a 32-bit integer
probably so this is how we wouldn't
check the math function right so math
dot log would now be available for us at
math underscore log in rust and then we
can go ahead and say okay and we need a
third function
oops okay good and that is the console
log function again and this time we want
to add a 32-bit integer into it so we
would say this is now console on the
secure log on the score I 32 like this
so now we have both methods in there
right
so we now injected the math logarithm
function and we injected console.log but
under completely different names so they
are not kind of messing up our brains
the selection
okay so let's try to do that this is a
short exercise just trying to do
whatever function you would like pass it
in see if you can call it if you can
alert hellos like this example that I
think other year you could do a alert
hello world or something and have fun
with it
yeah let's take five to ten minutes try
that out and that will be the last basic
exercise after that we will do some fun
image processing that we actually see
what webassembly is capable of we just
had to learn the basics first so we
understand what happens under the hood
okay let's already get into that because
this is just a last quick exercise let's
just do the basic example right I think
most of you already have it running if
not don't worry so if we have that
external block right this is all we do
we just have to call it from somewhere
so I mean we can make a new function
right so we can say well let's be honest
with our function names right let's call
it alert let's call it alert hello world
this gets in a string and we'll return
absolutely nothing so what we will do is
we will call alert like this right so we
can call that alert hello world and this
should actually call our alert functions
that we should get a stupid alert
message right so let's just try that so
instead of greeting here we just called
a new alert hello world like this and
since we don't have a return type this
line down here doesn't make any sense
so now we call it like that and this
should now throw an error because I did
leave something out that is relevant so
let's just giant build and run it and
see what rust says to that oh so it said
I am expecting you to add this reference
string but you give me a correct
complete string so what I have to do the
issue is now here I have the format
macro which is returning a string well
as you see alert is expecting this so
what I do is I ask that as I put the
reference of that
and rust will be totally happy with that
so let's see yeah you see up here well
it's not the best contrast so the native
alert of mine browser fired so if we go
here like confirm you know you know the
confirm right with the buttons on it
so let's just call the confirm now what
happens you see I got these buttons up
here so these are really their native
methods right we can call them now cool
so this was all for the basics I hope it
was okay for you it was fun for the
basics but now we want to see what an
actual real-world use case looks like so
how do we do for example image
processing but I would advise that we
make a short break of 10 minutes and
start with the last exercise at half
past three
soon but we will already start otherwise
we'll get into a hurry for our last
exercise and we don't want that so go
over to the the lowest the last one
chapter 5 real-world use case this is
what we will look at now so what do I
think of real-world use case um what we
will use this OpenCV does anybody in
here know OpenCV a bit are you are you
actively using OpenCV nobody really cool
so we won't do hard core functions of
open CV so I will explain every function
that we need for those who don't know
open CV it's one of the biggest
libraries for computer vision it is
written in C C++ so as you may think
this CV in open CV is computer vision
and the cool thing is in C and C++ right
and if you remember correct if you
remember from my first couple of slides
C and C++ are pretty much down there for
assembly so you can compile them to
webassembly very easily so let's do that
then luckily there is somebody at open
CD who already did this so the standard
build of open CV can be triggered to
compile to Basel instead of native
architecture code we won't compile it
ourselves because you would have to
install si Lang compiler and I'm
scripted and you would compile it for
five to ten minutes since that is kind
of a not so nice thing to do I did the
pre compiling for us so we already have
a
compiled OpenCV library and it's eight
megabytes big so it's not optimal to
send it to the browser often so we'll
try to catch it
oh yeah I forgot to mention your script
so we used vassal bind change for rust
right so that helped us with those
bindings from rust to JavaScript all C
and C++ side we have em strip them and
you can basically if if you put it very
simple that's not entirely correct but
if you put it simple it's comparable to
wasn't binds chain
it does also do JavaScript bindings it
will help us to have this high level
interaction with all the types we want
to so this is gonna help us a lot and
this is what OpenCV internally uses when
you compile it to webassembly so let's
do image processing shall we the first
thing you have to do is check out that
little git repository shouldn't be too
big this is the set up for our last - is
it - yeah - exercises that we will do
when you have it when you downloaded it
execute npm install and npm start and
then you should have a local running web
server on port 8080 or if your part ID
ID is actually taken it will start on
8081 8080 - whatever is free it will
show you in the console you will not
have to restart that web server because
it's just a plain static web server we
have no build come we have no build step
we have no post piece processing nothing
like that so this is really a stupid web
server so you don't have to restart it
or anything just keep it up and running
and the only thing you have to do is
refresh your browser
they actually changed things okay try to
check that out I hope everybody has an
editor River so like your favorite
editor on you we it's not like you need
a super-duper editor so you will be okay
with pretty much any editor
did everybody manage to clone to get
repository everybody has it
perfect cool as soon as you have it run
npm install and npm start and then you
should be able to visit localhost 8080
or whatever it says on the console if
you don't get a page shown i seen that
on some Windows machines that can happen
then just add a slash index dot HTML to
the URL sometimes HTTP server doesn't
automatically redirect you to the
index.html page I haven't really found
how to properly solve this so if this
happens just add slash index dot HTML in
the end and you should be good if
everything works alright you can open
the console and after some seconds you
should see that console message over
there runtime ready what that means is
whether somebody started with open CD in
it and open CV runtime is ready for you
we don't do anything yet with it so
don't worry if you don't see anything
cool
so do you see that less who sees that
message okay like half of you right okay
does anybody have like an error message
or just not there yet error messages
I'll come and see quickly
unless each part closed no first one or
do you have some sort of plug-in up
there that looks like a plug-in issue
because you see it's not from the main
chest open it in an incognito window for
once and see if you get that message
there - no okay so it's one of your
plugins don't worry about that
who has an issue - nobody oh cool
so who sees the console log message now
if some of you okay not too many let's
let's wait for another minute
anybody have exceptions or something are
you stuck
corrupted this looks good
can you try to add slash index dot HTML
okay that's that's that issue that I was
mentioning so I don't know why so if you
go to the console now you should see
that runtime ready know that browser
comes out sorry perfect there it is yeah
it's the browser console where that
console segment should be yet at the
terminal console
okay I hope that it works for you then
otherwise when we are at the exercise I
will come to the people that still have
issues good so what do we do from here
right that's not very interesting
a very short introduction to the protest
structure we have three main files to
the relevant in the binary folder you
have the OpenCV Deshaies file this is
the compiled open CV file maybe don't
open it there's a six megabyte
base64 encoded string with the complete
Bassem binary in it it might kill your
editor depending on what you use you can
open it you will see a lot of funny
letters but yeah may be done and then we
have the index.html and main shares so a
nice little web project no build staff
nothing so I kind of like it already
cool yeah I think I told you that so the
difference to what we did before this
one is not having a basin of the score
bind Chen on the window object what we
will get is a CD object so whenever you
want to interact with
OpenCV we will go over that CV dot
whatever it is and whatever function we
want to use cool so let's do our first
exercise first when we wanna have
real-time image processing we need some
sort of video stream right so let's go
into WebRTC who knows WebRTC okay not
too many so I'm gonna quickly quickly go
into it whatever you see we can
basically get streams of audio video or
both in the browser the idea the basic
idea where it came from is that we can
have video chats or audio chats in your
browser because that's dream that you
have you can send it over the network
and then it can basically make your own
Skype if you want to and that is pretty
much integrated in every browser
nowadays probably except for I
I wouldn't know this is just a random
guess we won't use that for sending it
over the net we will just fetch the
webcam camera off stream so we have a
stream that we can sample all right that
we can do image processing this is
actually not all that hard
what you do is navigated of media
devices this is where it's located up
and then it can say getusermedia and you
have an options object where you can say
what do you want if you look at the
documentation these don't have to be
bullying you actually can add a config
object so you can say I want the
front-facing camera I want the back
facing camera
I want it in landscape mode I want
whatever we are just gonna be very
simple here we say you have one webcam
stream probably on your notebook
I guess just give us that that's all we
need
it's a promise we can say then and in
here we will get the stream that's all
we want
cool but what do we do with that stream
now we can get the video tracks since we
are a very simple webcam there will be
one video track so we're just gonna say
give us that first video track can not
care about it anymore we will use that
video track later on you see it down
here we will have two width and the
height of our video stream on there we
don't use it from the start so don't
worry about it these are the settings
that we get from there
when you look at the JavaScript object
you see that on the top two lines I have
two elements that I get from the HTML
you can look at them it's a video
element and the canvas element the first
element we are going to use is the video
element so what we can do now the video
element has a property name source
object you can just set this dream on to
the source object and what will happen
is you will see yourself yeah so let's
try to do that get the video stream
added to the input object input video
element and see if you can see yourself
or if something goes wrong does anybody
still have problems with running the
project like basically running it cool
let's just take five minutes or 10
minutes for that depending on how long
it takes you but it shouldn't shouldn't
be too hard
okay so that's not really what we want
to do right that's just what we needed
to do to get an input stream so now we
want to have open CV right now we have
that input stream
and now we want to make sure that we
call our C library that we just cross
compiled or we would compile down to
Azen now we want to really call it and
see what happens so how do we do that
luckily open CV has a thing called video
capture that can capture frames from a
video element very convenient so we can
say where we have our video and then we
can say video capture dot read and it
will read a OpenCV matrix out of that
image and then we can work on that
matrix which is cool so this is how it
looks you need to have a global variable
cap and then you can instantiate it with
our input video element we can just say
CV dot video capture and we can
instantiate that with new and this is
how we create our first open CV object
right so open CV is now instantiating
that video capture thing for us so this
is already a very complex type right so
we can already share that between
webassembly and JavaScript which is kind
of fascinating already so this is how we
set it up now open CV know is there's a
video stream going on and we just have
to pass that into open CV now that we
can actually fetch what we need is the
output canvas needs to have my width and
the height we want to paint that picture
that we get from open CV onto a canvas
now so whatever we do our open CV we do
some transformations and whatever in the
end we can't put that back into the
video element we have to render that
image that we just did onto a canvas so
I made that HTML element already
available to you it's collage put canvas
and you have to make sure
the size of the canvas matches the size
of our stream otherwise OpenCV will
complain and say well you try to paint a
matrix onto a canvas and they are not
the same size this doesn't work so it's
important that we set width and height
of our canvas then we need two matrices
one is the source matrix this is what we
get out of the video stream and the
other is the destination matrix in
between we will do some conversion on
that main image right so we read a
matrix transform it into a destination
matrix paint that destination matrix
onto our canvas this is the steps you
are gonna do this is just how you
instantiate them also make sure that you
do that in that start streaming function
we don't want to create a new matrix
with every frame right this is not fun
because that would be heavy on the
memory we can always reuse the last
matrix right we don't have to do a new
matrix all the time yeah also here it's
important that height and width are
really correct and behind well in the
end of that line you can see these two
values of OpenCV what I mean is you have
heard that already 8-bit unsigned int is
8u and c4 means how many channels we
have when we read from our webcam we get
four channels
basically it's RGB and a alpha Channel
so this is what we get in and now for
our first exercise we're going to do a
grayscale so we reduce from four
channels to one channel that is only
gray we will remove all the colors that
is our first easy exercise that we're
going to try
yeah
so we have four things that we have to
do we saw it earlier we set up the video
capture at the matrices that is already
cool now we have to have some sort of
painting loop right so we have to read
from the video capture then we convert
to grayscale and then we draw to the
canvas and then we call us again and
then we have our basic animation loop
that will fetch from the video stream
grayscale all the things to draw onto
the canvas so how does that look like
the video capture is actually super easy
you say dot read and hand in the source
matrix so what it will do it will
transform that image to a matrix so now
our source matrix has an image in it
cool then we convert the color so OpenCV
has a method called convert column so we
say we go from the source matrix we will
write into the destination matrix and
this is the color transformation that
you have to apply we go from RGB a to
grayscale and last but not least we make
an e/m show it's called I am sure we
have to input the canvas element here so
OpenCV knows about that canvas element
and we say which matrix should be
printed onto our drawn onto that canvas
and since the destination matrix is now
our grayscale matrix this is what we
want to do
and Indians loop it
who knows requestanimationframe in here
cool cool ok so for the ones that don't
know it we can ask the browser to call
us in 60 frames per second if possible
this is that function we can hand in the
function and the browser will schedule
us and we'll try to call us every what
is it 13 minute seconds so we have 60
frames per second if that doesn't work
if we are too slow he will just schedule
us as fast as he can without blocking
his rendering loop so this is just a way
that the browser makes sure we are not
spamming user interaction between
browser and JavaScript so in the end of
our function we can say okay we are done
now please reschedule us we want to draw
again and then the browser will let us
draw again yeah this is it so you have
all the codes you need for the exercise
put it together and see if you get a
greyscale image of yourself on the right
side let's say 10 minutes for now
exactly
that it has to be yet
mm-hm we can set that up here you don't
have to do it in there in the loop but
you can do it in the loop but you don't
have to that's work you need to do once
right and that's good yeah
oh yeah I would do let's see the
initialization of these things you can
also do up here right you don't you only
have to have to do that once Jesus
messaging I don't believe these martyrs
capture well not just are you stuck
actually yeah yeah this is we do
initialize all the opencv objects that
we use yeah and this is the function we
want to repeatedly call now right so
these actually do actual reading exactly
this is what we do when for each frame
right that we can so this part should be
in here you should call it from here
once but that function should stand
somewhere on its own like outside of
your context for example that's why we
save these things into the global scope
okay so
funny inside humanizing issue way yeah
it will work it will work so we can
leave it in there if you want to the
only relevant thing is that inside the
function you have to call that window
requestanimationframe again right
because like this you will only be
called once and you have to tell the
browser yeah okay that should work
Oh sounds of input monster-sized should
be the same as to video let me see
oh oh you have to do that after you set
the stream because before that it will
not oh no no no I should work you should
work your right service I'm getting the
ready fun
the video tracker on that should be
alright yes you're right um can you try
to set the width and height of the input
video as well the same way you do it up
there just for the input a video yeah no
no just copy duplicate right right below
them is yeah no no right below right
here
so here and now do it on the input video
instead of the output canvas so both are
set to the same size you know the input
video is the video element right try to
do it there yeah
yes okay try that
it's okay yeah
so there are two lines of codes missing
I am very sorry I made that example up
here that you have to set the canvas
width and height I forgot to mention
here you have to do the same on the
input video element otherwise OpenCV
will complain and say your video is not
the same as your canvas so you have to
do these two lines for the input video
as well you can do it on the same spot
sorry I forgot that
with black black why is it black what
happens o your own function oh you need
to do it this part in one specific
function that can call itself again
right you can do that outside whatever
you want you can say like processed
video or something
yeah
exactly and then I can
you need to put that into here as well
the function I have to exact perfect
that's your work
yes there you go yeah yeah
okay where are you let me quickly see so
the width of the height you can get from
these settings settings has width and
height on it so maybe do all of these
things up here like until cap read like
this whole block you don't you only have
to do once so you don't need to do that
and they can really capture too you can
do that up there this one yeah
so you only need this in your actual
function
yeah and then you can go for a setting
start with yeah and settings tonight
exactly perfect okay so that looks good
now we just have to make sure that that
window requestanimationframe is inside
your function because you want at the
end when you are done right you want it
to be cold again cool try it
Oh doesn't allow you to do that okay
okay almost do we get an error message
nothing so can you show me the function
again
that looks good we have for Charles this
actually looks good
I don't see your issue sit back foodie
honking yeah that's good with Heights
you're doing it the right way
huh
you can't currently see what issues any
real of the rats
huh
can you try it this is are you using
Chrome or Firefox
can you try it in Chrome just for a
quick try not that it should it should
work for for Firefox as well just want
to make sure that this is not some weird
bug okay cool we are having an actual
error but I don't see it currently so
input video is the capture you have
video hide video with settings with
settings I made Russia
no you don't have to do anything on the
HTML or you shouldn't shouldn't host it
that looks all good
kappa source test
process ready
you go down again like justice right so
you be color
RGBA to gray oh oh it's to greyscale I
think isn't it
can you check under or did you copy it
this one now it's down huh that's weird
can you actually in my opinion you're
doing the right thing yeah I don't see
you
and I can't really know that
unfortunately you see it in the browser
though if you go to the page where you
have it open and you enter CV dealt
color oh you have to write it and small
RGBA
this is weird
I'll have to continue and there's a
branch if the solution we can then look
at it what what happens
okay so I hope most of you have gotten
it to work somehow I included a
solutions wrench so if you check out the
branch solution grayscale it will do the
code that you need and it should work
for you all so what do you have to do oh
this is a bit small can you read that
so good so what you needed to do is I
did the specific pixel width you could
omit the pixel because the browser is is
thinking that you need pixels when you
don't say anything
so there's pixel height and we set that
on the input video and the output canvas
we said it on the source object display
that I added in is basically for iOS
Safari because Safari is very
restrictive about how to apply Auto
playing videos so you don't need that
specifically I added it in that it works
on most browsers then we have the matrix
settings as you see in them the video
capture setup and then we say go ahead
process video so what do you see here I
have a little I have added a little
something in a frame counter so you
would go with read converter color show
and then requestanimationframe again so
let's let's just look at it right let's
go for localhost 8080 voila this is how
it should look like
hello and you see up here we are getting
60 frames per second well 59 frames per
second this is what it should look like
so that's a very easy example I mean
gray scaling isn't supposed to take a
lot of processing power but we can do
something else
does so let's look at that now let's go
to that oh yeah memory leaks we are in
see so we have a lot of gels with memory
leaks now since we start when the
webpage loads up and we end when the
webpage is closed we don't need to care
as much but usually all these objects
the matrices have a delete function on
them if you don't need them anymore you
would actually have to call delete
because yeah it's C right we have to
free memory it won't be garbage
collected yeah but in our example we
won't have to care about that as much so
let's go to the fun part right so we
have a stream we have open CV an open CV
can handle classifiers if you have been
at the talk yesterday I think it was
about classifiers that can detect is it
a cat or a dog we will use a classifier
that can detect is it a face or is it
not a face it's not the best classifier
so you will be able to fool it somehow
but it is an OK classifier so that's the
first thing we need classifier then we
need to run that classifier with each
frame we already have set up that loop
now right and if it didn't work for you
check out the solution branch then you
have dances that loop set up then we get
a vector which is basically an array
right so we can go through this vector
with faces and draw these as rectangles
on our video stream the classifier that
we're going to use is called har cascade
classifier that's a pre trained
classifier I haven't done that this is
from OpenCV they provide that that's
like a standard classifier for you to
choose so we don't have to train that
right we don't want to train it to you
we don't have time for that so we can
just take that pre-trained one then we
load that it's an XML and we give it to
open CV you don't have to do that
because it's a bit cumbersome we have to
fetch it make a byte array input into
open CV I already did that for you and I
did it on a branch called exercise face
detection so when you start this
exercise checkout exercise face
detection so what we have to care about
now is we run the classifier the
classifier is designed to run on a
grayscale image so you already know how
that works but with the end result let
me show you the end result so there's
also a solution face detection please
don't go right there that won't be fun
but we will do it now that you see what
we are trying to achieve at least so
let's go on there so here you see oh you
see there is actually something up there
that looks oh he recognizes my face over
up here that's cool he's not social oh
now he's pretty sure but this is also a
face so you see it's not the best face
detection algorithm but it's okay it's
okay so we don't want this image to be
grayscale right that wouldn't be fun so
what we have to care for is that we have
a new matrix that is not grayscale
because that crazy can run we
for the classifier so we will have a
third matrix that is just to show to the
users that is looking cool right that
has all four channels on it so we need
to we basically need a copy of our
source matrix for them so this is how we
can copy a matrix nothing very fancy
around here this matrix for the
grayscale we don't have to initialize
with height and width because we are not
growing it going to put it on the canvas
or read it from the camera so we will
get the source matrix in here and it
will get the size of that source matrix
just inherently so this is basically
what we do instead of from source to
destination we go from that copy its
destination thing to gray that new
matrix that we just initialized up here
just one more matrix then we need to
instantiate a vector where our algorithm
will put the faces and so we know what
faces he found and this is how the
classifier is then run you can look at
the bottom this is where you see how the
classifier is accentuated
but it's a bit cumbersome so don't worry
about that we have to load the XML files
and everything so this is just a new
classifier with that XML file that we
just loaded detect multiscale so it will
scale the image and multiple factors and
try to see which faces are real faces on
all scaling factors so he is pretty sure
that this is a face the values down here
or at the end here these are values that
probably people
actual experience in image processing
can tell you more about I don't know
them very well these are just like
default values to have a basic face
detection algorithm running so when we
do that here you see that we put in that
faces vector after this one run that
face vector has faces on it so we just
need to loop through that lecture and
paint these faces easy as that this will
look something like this since this is a
C object now right that that vector is
not a JavaScript object our script array
you can't do that for each dot map or
dot filter so you have to do a classical
for loop over it get the size with dot
size and get the face with that in the
x-axis a face has four things on it XY
where it is and width and height so we
only have to draw a rectangle before
OpenCV this is called the CV dot
rectangle
this is how it will look like we draw it
on the destination matrix so we will
make a rectangle on the destination
matrix we need two points here I gave
you the code for one point this is top
left how you get to the bottom right is
your exercise and this is the color
RGBA so this will be red you can do
whatever color you want to there one one
small note i scaled down the inputs to
320 pixels this is where the algorithm
works best usually you wouldn't do that
visibly to the user you would take the
matrix scale it down internally give it
to the classifier and then scale up the
rectangles again and put out the output
destination matrix would be full scale
again so the user has best possible
resolution but this is just more code so
what I did is just
cropped the whole inputs that's in input
matrix to 320 pixels that's not very
nice but it is fast and performant yeah
so you can go to the exercise face
detection branch and try to get that up
and running and you also can try to fit
a little bit with parameters and colors
and you can also do circles if you want
to draw a circle around the face
whatever you like to if you want to
check it out I deployed the solution of
the cloud so you can go onto here and
you can try it out so you see what you
should be aiming for
so I see that already some of you are
leaving so before all of your gum there
are two things I want to say we will
quickly look at the solution so you can
work on that on your own if you want to
and I will do a little quiz to get some
Swiss chocolate so the three best ones
will get boots a big chocolate so let's
quickly look at the solution just brush
over it very quickly so you see the only
change that we have to do is in process
video we will copy to that new
destination matrix we make that new
grayscale matrix then we run that multi
scale classifier and then we loop over
all phases the bottom right point we can
just say face dot X plus width and face
the Y plus height right so we get the
bottom right or from your point of view
the bottom right point that makes more
sense and the rest is the same right we
have that rectangle and we still do
image show so if you checked it out I
think we are not getting the best frame
rates there are people that optimize
this better so if you look at it I think
before we not we so before we were able
to get up to 15 frames per seconds
sometimes here you see now 14 15 frames
per second not very good so if we would
be optimizing that thing and website
people did that you see we would get
they get 30 frames per second for web
assembly they did a comparison to us and
choice and native that's the same kind
of algorithm we are using just we are
not using it very optimized with just do
a very simple example so if you do it
with a some chairs it is around 20
frames per second and native JavaScript
is
at two frames so this is where actually
near-native performance makes a very big
difference if you want to be somewhere
close to real-time or something in that
direction you should totally go for
webassembly in that direction cool
yeah I think that's probably my sum up
of everything you don't need to use
webassembly to have minor road
improvements on your transcript code
base or something like that where
assembly is meant to run heavy stuff so
use it for that don't use it to get your
angular app faster or something like
that that's not whatever it will be your
firm cool so all the resources we used
all the stuff we can read up on I mean
you have to link to my presentation now
yeah let's do a little twist in the end
I think I've already seen that there is
this Kahoot thingy right so
go to cahoots Delta IT and enter that
pin and your name and then we can have a
fun little Chris and after that we will
be done okay we have multi nicknames oh
okay okay cool
and ice
cool are we all is there somebody wants
to join we're all good so get ready
oh oh I [ __ ] up with the logo sorry
what's the short form of webassembly
you have 10 seconds time the earlier you
click the more points you will be
rewarded ooh and they all already
answered that whoo yeah and obviously
some might have clicked wrong right but
almost everybody knew that cool so we
have somebody in front Johnny I hope I
pronounced that right I'm sorry if I
didn't say cool what's the next question
what was our IDE code that we used for
our basic examples
yeah I think way too easy questions for
you guys
way too easy oh well okay there was
somebody was very fast on that okay
move up to the next question how do we
tell the RUS compiler to not remove our
function
so easy questions I need that so easy
cool yeah whoo it is still up for all
nice let's go on to the next question
what's the name of the computer vision
library we used yeah who's the fastest
precedence rules
so somebody click wrong
Oh didn't take my clique uppers so
Kahoot seems to be very fast at school
let's go to the last question how many
employee is the sukkah Singapore have
currently I mean there has to be one to
this side right so it is 34 is it 35 it
is 36 or 37
oh that's a nice curve there cool okay
that was a fun question for the end so
that we definitely have a kind of people
on top so congrats to these three people
come up front in the end you can collect
your table round here I hope you have
fun during that workshop and that you
like webassembly now as much as I do and
yeah have a nice rest of the conference
[Applause]